das nächste thema ist das hier tausende
demonstrieren gegen die korona maßnahmen
in münchen stuttgart und berlin
aber wer geht da hin und warum
rechtsextreme verschwörungstheoretiker
oder auch normale bürger
der chef des bundeskriminalamts wand
wieder aufkommen den demonstrationen
sehen wir das ist vor allem versuche
gerade aus dem rechten spektrum proteste
aus dem bürgerlichen lager zum konsens
jetzt mal um dort auch ihre
weltanschauung und theorien zu
verbreiten
am rande einer demo in berlin dann der
angriff auf ein kamerateam der zdf-
heute-show vier verletzte mussten ins
krankenhaus gebracht werden
auch thüringens ex-ministerpräsident
thomas kemmerich nimmt an einer demo
teil ohne mundschutz und ohne
mindestabstand fdp chef lindner schreibt
die aktion von kemmerich schwächt unsere
argumente
ich habe dafür kein verständnis ist also
unser grundrecht auf
versammlungsfreiheit in gefahr
tja christian hat gesagt er hat dafür
kein verständnis das sagst du uns auch
seit einigen wochen plädierte für dieses
thema also ich glaube dass das ganz
wichtig ist das sozusagen das worauf
sich die verschwörungs ideologen berufen
genau das ist was sie uns ja vor
nehmende dadurch entstehen diese bilder
also sie habe mitnichten so dass wir uns
in einer diktatur befinden und bei allem
verständnis sei nicht mal auch für das
recht auf demonstration das ist ein
grundpfeiler unserer demokratie und das
ist selbstverständlich allen und jedem
gestattet
es ist wichtig sich genau anzugucken in
welcher gesellschaft begebe ich mich
denn da wenn ich sozusagen auf meine
grundrechte poche und für meine
grundrechte so demonstrieren
denn es ist inzwischen leider so dass
darunter antisemiten sind
rechtspopulisten sind verschwörungs
ideologen die sich als freiheitskämpfer
auftun die ich aber als feinde der
demokratie bezeichnen würde
und es ist für mich auch ein pedal
moment also ich finde das dann in
dialektik ist auch zu sozusagen
flüchtlings herausforderung 2015
und es sind dieselben reaktionen die
ausgelöst werden durch unsicherheit
durch existenzängste und corona wirkt
jetzt erst also das geht jetzt erst
richtig auf und da brauchen die menschen
ein ventil
aber ich finde es ganz wichtig zu
benennen ross und reiter wer ruft zu
diesen demonstrationen auf also das ist
nachweislich so dass auch ein canon
epson zum beispiel antisemitische
verschwörungstheorien inne hat und dass
diese antisemitismus klammer eigentlich
wie ein roter faden durch gezogen wird
und es ist auch die lust auf unwahrheit
also auf die bestätigung dafür dass wir
sozusagen regiert werden oder dass so
die systemfrage gestellt wird und da
glaube ich bei aller unzufriedenheit
also gerade auch in richtung emmerich
ist es ganz wichtig in welchem umfeld
bewege ich mich hier eigentlich und ich
finde da macht man kein freifahrtschein
und da ist wirklich schade
das ist echt schade weil ich finde schon
menschen die demonstrieren die sollte
man ernst nehmen und das ist auch völlig
in ordnung wenn ich da meine meinung
kundtue wir leben in einer demokratie
aber es gibt jetzt ebenso viele
trittbrettfahrer
ich verstehe im moment auch dass manche
aggressiv sind es gibt existenzängste es
gibt unzufriedenheiten was ich nicht
akzeptiere
das ist dieser hass auch auf die
regierung dieses beschimpfen unzufrieden
seien gegen alles und jeden aber dann
sollen doch diejenigen bitte auch mal
lösungsvorschläge liefern die haben sie
nämlich nicht und das ärgert mich wenn
man immer nur sagt das alles ist macht
aber nicht besser und hat keine lösung
für die probleme im moment sind aber
auch ganz viele muss man auch sagen es
sind nicht alle demonstranten spinner
also mir geht es im moment auch manchmal
zu weit dass wir sagen ja das sind die
alu hut träger die verschwörung es gibt
auch menschen die einfach ganz
hinterfragen gerade und ich frage mich
wo ist ihr platz wo können sie gerade
heute fand ich war in den studien
beispiel ja virtuell aber dass es geht
karl heinz hat vielleicht nicht nur
internet und twitter usw sondern er
möchte vielleicht klassisch raus und
seine meinung kundtun weil der hat keine
tausend follower schafen auf die
erzählen kann und nicht mal twitter oder
instagram und nutzt das nicht so und ich
finde gerade heute es wird ganz oft eben
einfach auch das vertrauen wieder auf
die probe gestellt wenn wir heute eher
von einem geheimpapier sprechen
das vom referent von seehofer kommt und
dieser referent wird dann sofort laptop
kassiert und darf nicht mehr sprechen so
entsteht genau so entsteht misstrauen
bei glaube ich normalen bürgern dass man
eben nicht über den inhalt spricht und
man sagt hier wird ein punkt gemacht die
beschränkungen führen eventuell dazu
dass wir mehr tote haben weil
operationen anderen kranken menschen
nicht geholfen werden kann und wir
müssen über die inhalte sprechen wollen
wir dann aber den adressaten nicht zu
wort kommen lassen
dann wird es dazu führen dass ganz
normale menschen misstrauen haben und
auch das müssen sie irgendwo los aber
genau das passiert ja auch gerade das
ist ja das momentum sozusagen auf
unseres rechtsstaats dass wir
hinterfragen dass wir kritisieren dass
wir den politikern auf die finger gucken
das ist ja bürgerrecht und davon wird ja
auch gebrauch gemacht aber ich glaube
was viel wichtiger ist ist dass dieses
vakuum was gerade aufgeht dass das nicht
richtig besetzt wird und da ist glaube
ich auch sind wir als
solidargemeinschaft gefragt aber auch
die regierung das sozusagen man das
nicht den hasspredigern überlässt denn
das ist sozusagen ein momentum was immer
wiederkehrt je nachdem welchen
herausforderungen ausgesetzt sind und
ich sage mal diese psychische
pandemiewelle die jetzt erst richtig
wirkt die jetzt erst auf geht auf
menschen so dass sie letztlich manchmal
gar nicht wissen wie sie damit umgehen
sollen
wenn sie keine antwort haben auf ihre
alltagsprobleme und diese offenen fragen
gar nicht aushalten
genau das bewirkt natürlich dass die
menschen dann auf die straße die den
riesen in die hand rainer das muss die
politik interessieren oder ist es nicht
hilfreich wenn beispielsweise bayerns
fdp dann sagt ja der hashtag vollpfosten
zu den demonstranten auf twitter also
wenn wir die alle über einen kamm
stimmen vor allem die politik das macht
diese menschen über einen kamm zu
scheren
dann entsteht genau das was wir nicht
leben entschuldigen das problem ist
natürlich dass viele demonstranten
machen das kaputt das demonstrieren das
klassische demonstrieren dass man auf
die straße darf dass man seine meinung
kundtun darf weil sie ja erstens die
demonstration teilweise gar nicht
anmelden oder einfach von links rein
preschen in irgendwelchen anderen
gruppen wo sie überhaupt nichts zu
suchen haben und somit machen sie das
natürlich zunichte und es ist einfach
ein ausnahmezustand gerade und es wirkt
ist wie können nicht mehr als 150 zwei
meter voneinander oder zusammenkommen
und das ist das was ich eingehalten wird
und das ist ein gesetz das gesetz wird
nicht eingehalten also geht es nicht und
das macht das ganze extrem traurig finde
aber geht's euch nicht auch so also bei
mir ist es jetzt wirklich so schaue ja
auch jeden tag nachrichten und ich
informiere mich über das virus
ich finde es melden sich einfach zu
viele menschen zu wort
ist da wieder irgendein ein doktor da
ein professor daten virologe
aus einer wirklich chaos und ich glaube
das ist das was die menschen zu
verunsichert ist so viele verschiedene
zahlen und einer sagt es ist völlig
ungefährlich der nächste sagt aber wenn
wir alle daran sterben das ist doch klar
dass die menschen verunsichert sind mir
geht es genauso
und dass es eben das wo man jetzt so ein
bisschen aufpassen muss auch was ich so
im netz verbreitet an videos
verschwörungstheorien und wir sind
gerade wirklich unglaublich in einer
ganz gefährlichen phase wo die leute
einfach auch sagen wisst ihr was ich
habe es einfach gar keinen bock mehr
daran sollten wir das gegenteil tun wir
sollten wenn wir auf die straße gehen
sollten wir uns abfeiern deutschland ist
im vergleich zu allen anderen ländern
vorneweg der die wirtschaftlichen folgen
wäre nicht so groß sein wie in
frankreich wie in italien wie in der
schweiz wir haben nicht so viele tote
wie eben in solchen ländern die menschen
dort dürfen gerade mal jetzt langsam das
was wir die ganze zeit schon dürften
nämlich raus
ich finde im moment könnten wir
rausgehen wir werden überall gelobt die
new york times erlebte unsere kanzlerin
will sich ich musste einmal feiern ich
verstehe dich total nur leider verstehen
dass sehr viele andere nicht deswegen
als noch mal den rasen genau über nutzen
das dann leider hause